reverend robert plott is an educated man
a professor of chemistry the prestigious
university of oxford
but he is as excited as a child at
christmas when new parcels arrive
in 1677 he hurries around the grass
squad of university college
and bursts through the heavy oak door of
the ground floor lodgings
it is just as well there on the ground
floor because the parcel that greets him
fills the entranceway
it is a huge crate
battered and splintered it must have
taken three or four porters to bring it
inside
not to mention the poor horses that
pulled it all the way from cornwall
plot wastes no time in prying the wooden
slats apart and revealing the bounty
within
nestled among straw and wooden shavings
there are rocks
curious shapes and patterns each
accompanied by notes written in loose
flowing cursive
he pulls each one out briefly admiring
it turning it in his hands before
setting it down and reaching in for the
next
when the crate is almost empty his
searching hands encounter a smooth
rounded surface
it takes two hands to pull it from its
nest the reverent marvels at this unique
specimen
two rounded bulbs join where they touch
and morph into a smooth cylindrical stem
with a seemingly hollow center
to plot it looks
like a bone
but it is made from stone
and it is unimaginably huge
at this time in the late 17th century
debate runs rife among natural
historians as to the true nature and
origin of fossils
some believe them to be the remains of
ancient creatures long since dead while
others prefer to dismiss them as tricks
of the eye shapes that are formed
naturally by the growth of salt crystals
beneath the ground
still suggest that fossils are the
so-called seeds of plants and animals
that have descended deep into the earth
and begun to germinate there
but robert plot is a skeptical man of
science
and with no way that he can see for
living things to be preserved in solid
rock
he tends to favor the salt crystal
interpretation
he has spent the last few years studying
the shell-like fossils found in
oxfordshire quarries
likening them to the crystal patterns
produced by of all things crystallized
urine
[Music]
but not all structures to be found in
the rocks can fit this simplistic
crystalline explanation
plot eventually concludes that this
magnificent specimen is in fact
a petrified leg bone of some
unimaginably large creature
perhaps it comes from something like the
impressive roman war elephants he saw in
the flesh just a year earlier or perhaps
it belongs to a long lost race of giants
and so 100 years later the bone now part
of oxford's natural history collections
is studied again by another man of
science
richard brooks
[Music]
the understanding of fossils had
advanced by this point and many more
accept the possibility that they are
remnants of long dead creatures
and brooks is keen to use his knowledge
of animal and human anatomy to interpret
this curious specimen
for the first time he gives the rock
a name
[Music]
he calls it scrotum humanum making clear
the fossil's kinship with a certain
specific part of a giant human's anatomy
of course brook's interpretation was a
little off the mark
we have no evidence of a race of giant
humans either by the bones or the stones
they left behind
plot's cornish bone has now been
identified as the thigh bone of a
megalosaurus
the first dinosaur ever to be described
since the dawn of paleontology
scientists have been forced to challenge
the assumptions about what is and isn't
possible
about what earth's rocks really tell us
plot and his contemporaries were
occupied with whether fossils were even
real at all
but now we use them as a tool to probe
our own multi-billion year history
how much can the fossil record show us
how far does it go back
can we use it to find the first complex
life
and how can we be sure our
interpretations are correct
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blinkist an
excellent tool for absorbing knowledge
wherever you are
ever wanted to read a classic book but
simply couldn't find the time
well blinkist is here to help you out
breaking down epics ranging from sapiens
to the origin of species into 15-minute
bite-sized chunks
you can easily absorb on your commute or
other times that would otherwise be
wasted
it's a truly excellent tool for lifelong
learners and a great accompaniment to
our channel should you wish to learn
more
[Music]
like other educational apps all you need
to do is download the app sign up for an
account and you can listen wherever you
are and when you do make sure to use our
link we've teamed up with blinkist to
offer you an exclusive 7-day free trial
and 25 offer premium membership
more than 5 000 titles are already
available with more being released all
the time
so click on the link in the description
below to activate your free trial now
thanks
now back to earth's distant past
[Music]
the chances of anything becoming a
fossil beard a towering t-rex or
diminutive dragonfly are vanishingly
small
the circumstances and conditions that
allow traces of life to persist through
geological time are so few in number as
to be almost impossible to engineer or
predict
normally when an organism dies it is
simply eaten by another creature
recycled back into the great circle of
life
even if not consumed by a predator or
scavenger microscopic detritivores and
saprophytes colonisers of forest floors
riverbeds and ocean bottoms make short
work of any organic matter that falls
into their domain
[Music]
bacteria break down and water washes the
rest away leaving only the hardest bones
and shells
in time these two will oxidize and
crumble away to dust that becomes soil
and nutrients for the next generation of
life
this is the fate of almost anything that
has ever lived
to be so thoroughly broken down to our
component molecules and reincarnated in
the next
cycle of life
but in some exceedingly rare cases
a dead organism against all probability
is able to break the wheel
to escape the endless cycle
[Music]
there are a few places on earth where
the relentless recycling of organic
matter is sufficiently slowed to allow
some remnant of a creature to persist
long enough to leave a trace in the
rocks
perhaps an animal is washed away to the
ocean depths never stopping anywhere
long enough to become food
perhaps a fallen tree is so quickly
covered by mud and sand as a river
breaks its banks that it's swamped
before the rod sets in
or perhaps a freak change in water
chemistry is enough to kill everything
stuck within its toxic extent
excluding potential scavengers for many
years to come
[Music]
of course life on earth is famed for its
tenacity
and there are a few physical or chemical
phenomena that can keep voracious
bacteria at bay
even in the deep dark ocean depths
meters below the surface of atari swamp
or in a seemingly toxic pool of acid
there will be bacteria able to survive
and feed on the organic bounty that
comes their way
soft flesh is easy pickings for these
microscopic scavengers and they leave
only those hard parts bones teeth and
shells that are too tough to consume
so in these dark buried chemical
exclusion zones the hard parts persist
and become one with the rock
[Music]
over time the soft sediments are
compressed by the weight of more
deposited on top
water is squeezed out
new minerals are precipitated and old
minerals are lost
fossilization is now a race between
chemical and geological processes
as sediments turn into rock can new
minerals move in and preserve the
structure of the bones teeth and shells
before the original minerals are lost
[Music]
in the rare cases that they do
a fossil is born
if not then even the hardest of shells
is dissolved and the void it left
crushed out of all existence
[Music]
this unforgiving gauntlet which every
dead organism must run if it hopes to be
granted a fossil afterlife
sees only one bone in a billion
preserved within the rocks
for creatures with no natural hard parts
or which live far from the kind of
environments that favor preservation the
odds are stacked against them
paleontologists estimate that less than
0.1 percent of all species that have
ever lived have become fossils
and far fewer of those fossils have
actually been found
nevertheless and perhaps testament to
the sheer number of organisms that have
walked swam flew or slithered across the
earth there is an astounding wealth of
fossils to be found in our rocks
the very existence of a fossil record is
what defines an entire eon of earth
history
the phanerozoic from 541 million years
ago to today is so named in greek after
the visible life within rock layers
dating to this time
there are bones teeth and shells
but also the impressions of trees and
leaves and in especially rare cases
footprints
fur and feathers
reverend robert plot was among the first
to tap into this phanerozoic treasure
and in the centuries since paleontology
has grown to interpret life evolution
and environment on the basis of these
fossil remains
[Music]
and tracing the fossils of the
phanerozoic back through time a pattern
emerges
of increasing simplicity with increasing
age
[Music]
large and complex skeletons give way to
more rudimentary carapaces and modest
shells
and then to first appearances at least
in the lowermost cambrian rocks that
mark the beginning of the phanerozoic
the fossils
just
stop
[Music]
charles darwin himself remarked in 1859
upon the strange and sudden termination
of our paleontological lifeline into the
[Music]
past the problem of earth's missing
pre-cambrian life has come to be known
as darwin's dilemma
how could complex hard-shelled life have
seemingly sprung from nothing
541 million years ago
[Music]
where did all that complexity come from
and why can't we see it
the answer we know now is that we simply
didn't know where to look
against all possibility there are
impossible fossils lurking in rocks
from long before the eon of so-called
visible life
[Music]
in the northwestern corner of arizona
the colorado river cuts deep through
flat layer cake strata of the
phalarozoic
carving out one of the most magnificent
geological features on earth
the grand canyon
[Music]
and on a cool autumn day at the end of
the 19th century the chief
paleontologist of the u.s geological
survey picks his way down the narrow
switchbacking path descending deeper
into the canyon
and deeper
into time
[Music]
charles doolittle walcott is a
self-taught geologist
he began his paleontological career as
no more than a professional fossil
collector
and yet his eye for something new and
special among the ordinary proves the
key to his academic success
never having been told what should or
should not be geologically possible
he looks at the world with fresh
unbiased eyes
seeing things that his contemporaries
want to overlook
[Music]
descending into the cool shadowy depths
of the grand canyon woolcott spans
thousands of years with each downward
step
until near the chasm's floor a single
stride suddenly transports him 200
million years deeper into the past
he has crossed an unconformity
a sharp boundary in the rocks marked not
by gradual deposition but by ages of
erosion
in this case 200 million years of time
have been lost
walcott was first walking upon familiar
cambrian rocks
but is now adrift in the pre-cambrian
among rocks that are some 750
million years old
these are the layers he has come to see
and with his collector's eye he is quick
to assess the geology before him
his attention is soon caught by a
strange pattern
something he has never seen before in
rocks of any age
seen from the side perpendicular to the
rock's bedded strata there are domed
cabbage like layers
sometimes broad sometimes tight and
compact
even pointed
when surfaces parallel to the bedding
are exposed the tight layers are
successively cross cut to form fine
concentric rings
without any comparison walcott considers
what could have formed these curious
structures
their layering is much finer than the
grains of the surrounding rocks would
seem to allow
and their shapes are not those easily
formed by any physical processes he
knows in his notebook alongside their
sketches he posits that they could have
been shaped by some kind of ancient life
although precisely what kind of life
he isn't sure
he gives them a new name
cryptozuon
meaning hidden life
and reflecting the many questions still
surrounding these strange formations
[Music]
many more examples of cryptozuon were
subsequently discovered in pre-cambrian
rocks
but it wouldn't be until the 1950s long
after wolcott's death that this hidden
life would be revealed for what it
really was
in several salty bays of western
australia rocky blobs cluster in the
tidal shallows
and ecological analysis revealed these
smooth domes to be composed of a layer
upon a layer of fine sediment and
organic matter
and in the uppermost layers
photosynthesizing cyanobacteria reach
for the sun these are stromatolites
multi-layered microbial tower blocks in
which only the uppermost levels are
occupied
they grow with geological slowness
driven by the photosynthetic need for
the sun
tidal waters wash fine sediment over
their tops and the cyanobacteria must
form a new layer on top if they are to
survive
shaped by tidal ebbs and flows and the
gentle action of waves in the bay the
layers are molded into individual domes
cauliflower-like in cross-section and
concentrically ringed when eroded flat
[Music]
these living stromatolites are a perfect
match for the cryptozoons walcott found
in the grand canyon
and just as the modern domes are formed
by life
so too are there petrified precambrian
twins
charles doolittle walcott had
unwittingly found the first evidence for
life before the phalerozoic
proving darwin's assertion that life did
indeed exist in the precambrian and
offering a hint as to why it was still
hidden to
us quite simply
because it was too strange to be
believed
[Music]
since the mid-20th century realization
that the pre-cambrian fossil record does
indeed exist if only we know where to
look proterozoic paleontologists have
had to challenge their assumptions and
put aside their biases about where and
how some of the earliest forms of life
might be preserved
now the scales have fallen from our eyes
and the jewels of the precambrian are
revealed
we may not find bones or teeth or even
simple shells
but we do find hints and clues of the
life that existed before this
mineralized protection
when the stage was set for this complex
life to find its figurative feat
[Music]
it may seem an impossible task to
preserve a soft squishy organic body in
the face of biological recycling but as
stromatolites have shown us there are
certain quirks of rock formation that
allow even microscopic bacteria to be
preserved throughout eons
in this case sufficiently large
communities of tiny organic organisms
are able to exert enough influence on
their local environment that the normal
processes of rock formation are subtly
altered
with a thorough understanding of the
kinds of structures life can build today
we can search the rocks for such traces
as well
for instance tidal estuaries are ideal
habitats for microorganisms that don't
mind the brackish parts salty waters
that wash over them
nutrients delivered by the river are
deposited along with fine sand and mud
in shallow tidal waters that are
protected from the worst of the
battering waves
here vast layered communities of
microbes can grow on and in the sediment
spreading out to make the most of the
sun's rays
even if the conditions don't contrive to
build stromatolite tower blocks these
biomats can still leave a trace in the
resulting rocks
their surfaces become tufted and
wrinkled by the action of water on their
organically woven fabric
as the delta streams shift or storm
surges dump new sediment on top these
tufts and wrinkles are locked in place
and the unique chemistry of these
aqueous environments tips the balance of
petrification
allowing the patterns to be preserved as
molds and casts
before the organic matter of the biofilm
rots away
today pre-cambrian paleontologists scour
the top and lower surfaces of rocks for
these shadowy hints of wrinkled biomats
searching at sunset when the sun is low
reveals intricate patterns formed by sun
hungry biological fabric many hundreds
of millions of years ago
for many paleontologists today turning
over a slab to find its bottom surface
decorated with fine tufts and wrinkles
formed by ephemeral microscopic
organisms is a thrill akin to
discovering a dinosaur footprint
it is a brief moment of time
miraculously captured for the ages
[Music]
but there is an even more miraculous
process occurring in some of these
ancient rocks
if pre-cambrian paleontologists were
encouraged to set aside their biases
before now they must throw away the rule
book entirely
in the 1950s around the same time that
australian ecologists were discovering
living stromatolites geologists on the
opposite side of the world were
uncovering something even stranger
[Music]
elso baghorn and stanley tyler
investigated curiously carbon rich rocks
from the gunflint range of western
ontario
layers of coal-like rock contain no
fossils but they hint that life was
extremely abundant here abundant enough
to accumulate carbon within the
sediments themselves
elsewhere among the gunflint rocks they
find a dark glassy chert adding it to
their pack for analysis when they return
to the lab
[Music]
standard geological analysis often
involves slicing paper-thin sections of
a rock making it thin enough so light
can pass through it
and experts can identify the minerals by
their microscopic characteristics
but when tyler and barkhorn subject
their chert samples to this process
they find something they don't expect
speckled all throughout the fine
crystals of silicon dioxide there are
tiny grains of carbon
it's this that is responsible for the
chert's black color
but in places these specs are gathered
together in three-dimensional spheres
filaments and star-shaped groupings each
no more than around 10 microns or a
hundredth of a millimeter across
in both shape and size they resemble
living microbes
but they are nearly 2 000
million years old
could they really be biological in
origin
such delicate forms preserved
for so long
over the last 70 years since this
incredible gunflint discovery scientists
have found chemical and petrological
justification for how such impossible
fossils could come to exist
[Music]
remembering that fossilization is a race
between degradation and preservation for
the most delicate of organic structures
to be preserved then that preservation
needs to happen at an unprecedented rate
indeed the petrification process must
begin while these cells are still alive
certain quirks of chemistry more common
in the exotic and undisturbed seas and
lakes of the precambrian can see certain
mineral fluids become supersaturated in
natural waters
[Music]
silicon dioxide or phosphate ions build
up and are further concentrated by the
microbes that inhabit the sea floor
as they reach unsustainable levels and
the kind of gel begins to precipitate
the luckless microbes are encased in a
mineral tomb from which there is no
escape
deprived of the nutrients they need to
survive the cells die
[Music]
but they are already beyond the reach of
any that might reuse their carbon as the
mineral gel crystallizes and hardens the
cells are frozen in their death mask
protected even from the lifeless
chemistry that would reduce them to
formless blobs
if crystallization happens fast enough
then the cells are preserved in the
three-dimensional positions they
inhabited at the moment of their death
[Music]
if not and the gel is flattened by
sediments deposited on top then the
detail is retained but not their
positions
three dimensions are reduced to two as
the delicate fossils are flattened like
pressed flowers between layers of mud
and sand
this mineral sarcophagus is enough to
allow even the most delicate cells to
stand the test of time
as long as the rocks themselves survive
so does their microfossil treasure
when hundreds of millions of years later
paleontologists slice those rocks and
put them under the microscope
or dissolve away the crystalline tombs
with acid
they are greeted with delicate organic
walled forms that look remarkably
similar to modern cyanobacteria
algae and other single-celled microbes
just like insects preserved in amber
these appear to be cells that have been
frozen in time
only they are seven times as old and
many times smaller and more flimsy
it seems almost too perfect to be true
and indeed the true nature and antiquity
of such exceptionally preserved
microfossils has been called into
question many times
naturally the older the rock the more
questionable it is that the microfossil
bounty has survived intact
and these are not intricate insects in
amber but forms that are much more
simple
are they really biological cells that
are billions of years old
or is it simply wishful thinking
it has been said by pre-cambrian
paleontologists from both camps that
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
impossible fossils that seem to buck the
trend of all fossilization before them
must be subjected to more rigorous
validation than any other
we must prove that they are formed by
life and we must prove that they were
formed at the same time as the rocks
themselves not introduced later
luckily the science of exceptional
preservation has matured to the point
where such verification is now routine
along with documenting the shapes sizes
and associations of microfossils within
an ancient rock
experts also look for chemical signals
that suggest a biological rather than
chemical origin
they look for certain complexity and
structure which can't be achieved by
physical processes alone
and the surrounding rocks are analyzed
in minute and microscopic detail to calm
any fears that the microbes could have
been introduced after the minerals had
formed
[Music]
now organic walled microfossils from the
precambrian are no longer impossible
but an important part of our
paleontological inventory
stretching back at least two and a half
billion years
[Music]
it may not be a full picture
but some two centuries after his birth
it is a better picture than charles
darwin ever hoped to have
and we now begin the more challenging
task of interpreting exactly what it is
that picture shows
lynne margulis was not your traditional
scientist
once married to the famous cosmologist
carl sagan
she looked at the world of evolutionary
biology in her own unique holistic way
she wasn't interested in how one
organism functioned but pioneered
considering the links between even the
most disparate creatures
she didn't consider individual habitats
as their own isolated environments but
rather looked at the entire earth system
as a vast interconnected and
self-regulating
super organism
her theories were wild and unconstrained
by popular opinion
earning her the title
science's unruly earth mother
[Music]
one such theory took shape in her mind
in 1966 as she took up her post teaching
biology at boston university
she posited that the more complex
eukaryotic cells from which all higher
multicellular organisms are built came
about not from competition
but by cooperation
normally evolution by natural selection
brings about changes in living things by
favoring certain traits within a species
naturally occurring variation
under competitive conditions where
resources are scarce
but margulis suggested that in the case
of eukaryotes things happened a little
differently
[Music]
when nutrients ran short in the
ancestral prokaryotic world different
bacterial cells contrived to work
together
to increase both of their survival
chances
this pact or symbiosis was secured by a
physical association
one type of prokaryote would physically
come to live inside another
and reproduce alongside it
and thus margulis's theory of
endosymbiosis
took shape
it seems like a strange assertion
and indeed it was too strange too
unsupported by actual evidence for many
to accept it straight away
margulis submitted her paper to about 15
scientific journals before one the
journal of theoretical biology finally
agreed to publish it
she spoke about the theory everywhere
she went at scientific seminars
conferences workshops and even among
friends
but for a long time the idea of
bacterial cooperation was just too much
for many to countenance
for about 15 years lynn's ideas were
considered fringe science and perhaps
never taken completely seriously
but by the 1980s a new analytical
technique gave the endosymbiotic theory
the spark of credibility it needed
it was discovered that mitochondria the
famed powerhouses of the eukaryotic cell
have their own unique dna
that is unrelated to the dna of the host
later the same was shown to be true for
chloroplasts
margulis had claimed that these
structures were once independent
organisms
and now their genetic signatures were
indicating that was true
it looked like she had been right all
along
having ridden the endosymbiotic storm
from rejection through suspicion and
eventually to orthodoxy
helene margulis's unruly approach to
science only deepened and she developed
a taste for the controversial
she worked with james lovelock to give
substance to his gaia theory that the
earth is a single self-regulating super
organism
and fought hard to make her case for
five kingdoms of life animals plants
fungi single celled eukaryotic protists
and prokaryotic monera
she even went so far as to reject the
three domains of life that emerged from
genetic analysis of prokaryotes despite
the fact that it was this very genetic
analysis that had given substance to
endosymbiosis
[Music]
nevertheless as unorthodox as her
opinions and approach may have been
there can be no denying lynne margulis's
uncompromising passion for microscopic
life
and she was one of its most vocal
advocates
right up until her death in 2011.
[Music]
and of course there is a surprising
diversity of primitive life
are most commonly depicted as simple
pill-shaped rods but they can also be
spheres filaments loose spirals as well
as various bunched and tangled
associations of all these
in size they typically range from less
than a tenth of a micron to five microns
in length
modern eukaryotes by contrast are larger
and more complex
inside their cells they contain the
organelles obtained by endosymbiosis
including the mitochondria chloroplasts
and tail-like flagella
but they are also packed to bursting
with other cellular machinery and
internal membranes thought to have
evolved by more traditional natural
selective means
genetic material doesn't float freely
throughout the cell but is instead
contained in a membrane-bound nucleus
and there is an ephemeral but highly
organized structure to the gel-like
cytoplasm which helps coordinate the
complex processes of cell splitting and
sexual reproduction
it is called a cytoskeleton
it is this internal organization that
allows eukaryotes to become the basis of
all higher forms of life
the macroscopic multicellular organisms
that evolved much later
[Music]
if we are to search for eukaryotes in
the pre-cambrian fossil record we must
take a lesson from lynn margulis
and think laterally
if the internal features of this more
complex life aren't preserved then
instead we must search for features from
which we can infer a more complex
organization
[Music]
these are things that something only a
cell with organelles like a cytoskeleton
can accomplish
one such feature is the microfossils
size
in general prokaryotes tend to be
smaller than 5 microns in diameter and
eukaryotes are at least 10 microns
across
but even today we see exotic super-sized
bacteria or miniature eukaryotes
encapsulated colonies of bacteria can
easily reach a larger size and once
self-digestion occurs there is no way to
tell who the outer case belongs to
so size is a good first indication but
is by no means reliable
a much more reliable indication can be
found in the organic walls of the
microfossils themselves
a simple cell wall is easy enough to
build but any patterns or embellishments
require more cellular organization than
a prokaryote can muster
so paleontologists agree that any
organic microfossil that is adorned with
spines or other external structures and
ornamentation must in fact be derived
from a more complex eukaryote
[Music]
more simple outer walls and sheaths are
more difficult to pin down
but again some clues can point towards a
level of organization only possible with
complex internal machinery
many modern single-celled eukaryotes are
able to survive through periods of
environmental stress by encasing
themselves in more resistant cysts from
which they emerge when conditions are
improved
and nothing is more environmentally
stressful than suddenly being encased in
mineral gel
so we can expect to find these cysts
among the microfossil assemblages
[Music]
[Music]
the simple structureless innards of the
average prokaryotic cell could never
build a tree
or a jellyfish
or a human
it takes the complexity of a eukaryotic
cell to make the visible life on earth
as we know it
of course such complex machinery takes
time to evolve
even with endosymbiosis providing a leap
off the starting line
and it's thought that the boring billion
the period of unprecedented geological
stability between 1.8 and 0.8 billion
years ago
provided the perfect conditions to
gestate these
changes now that exceptional
preservation throughout the pre-cambrian
is offering us a window on the
microscopic life that thrived at this
time
can we find evidence of these monumental
evolutionary changes in the fossils
themselves
[Music]
and even possibly answer the question
what and when
was the first complex eukaryotic life
[Music]
a proterozoic fossil hunter is unlike
any other kind of paleontologist
walking among ancient rocks she doesn't
hope to find a promising curl or lump
producing from a rock's surface and she
would never expect to find her prize
washed up among the scree at the base of
a cliff
[Music]
instead she is meticulous about
documenting every geological detail of
the freshest exposure of rock she can
find collecting evidence from far and
wide to interpret the environment in
which these layers formed and what
geological torture they have endured
until now
in strata that is sufficiently unaltered
she scours the rock for minute
differences in the minerals that make
them up
extracting seemingly uninteresting
slivers from within these layers she
labels them carefully noting their
position and orientation
before unceremoniously tossing them into
our backpack among tens of others just
like them
packing them securely back at the hostel
for the flight home
[Music]
back at the lab it's time to process her
fines
some she will cut exposing fresh
surfaces that haven't seen the sun for a
billion years
and then mount those surfaces onto glass
slides and grind them until they are
just a few tens of microns thick
other samples she will dissolve in
hydrofluoric acid which will melt away
all rocks and minerals leaving only the
organic matter behind
this too will be mounted onto glass
slides and fixed in place
finally in a darkened room thousands of
miles from the journey start and
thousands of hours later she slips the
glass slide beneath her microscope
and peers with some trepidation through
the eyepiece
only then will she know whether she has
found something or not whether her
training and geological eye has revealed
a treasure of the proterozoic or if all
that work has been
for nothing
[Music]
it is an exhilarating feeling looking
through the eyepiece and finding the
bounty of the proterozoic laid out
and it's a feeling that many
paleontologists have experienced over
the years
there have now been countless
discoveries of microfossils from
proterozoic rocks all over the world
spanning huge swathes of time
[Music]
[Applause]
the gunflint biota including the
curiously star-shaped usatrian and
umbrella-like kakabikia is found
consistently in the gunflint church of
western ontario dating to 1.88 billion
years
other microfossils are found from rocks
all over the world indicating their
global dominance within the
mesoproterozoic
finely reticulated spheres of
dictiosphera sit alongside tapania and
shui use spheridium with their branching
and interlinking spines
all are found in rocks of china and
australia dating between 1.75 and 1.45
billion years old
slightly younger rocks of the
proterozoic dating to 1.2 billion years
are found in the hunting formation in
canada and these are host to a curious
association of seemingly differentiated
cells
different shapes are confined to
different parts of the organized
structure
and paleontologists believe this is one
of the earliest instances of complex and
consistent
multicellularity and sexual reproduction
by 1 billion years ago eukaryotic cells
have even made it out of the oceans and
onto land or at least into the
non-marine waters of the turidan lakes
of modern day northwest scotland
one species native to these ancient
lakes is by selem brassieri
also featuring differentiated cells
even before the end of the boring
billion it seems that life is already
well on its way to complex
multicellularity
but what of the deeper history of
eukaryotes
[Music]
our modern protozoa paleontologist no
longer needs to worry about a paucity of
fossils to study
to compare her finds with ones that have
already been documented she visits the
smithsonian museum of natural history
she wastes no time with the exhibits
impressive as they may be
walking past t-rex skeletons and
gigantic fossil stromatolites
to a small unmarked door in the corner
of one of the halls
[Music]
she steps through the door and into a
different world
gone are the information board's
creative lighting and screaming children
and she's instead faced with passageways
lined with cabinets gathering dust that
dulls their already monochrome colour
scheme
navigating this backstage labyrinth she
eventually finds herself in the same
room as the fossils she is searching for
but she still has to work to find them
the good thing about microfossils is
that they don't take up much room
but 70 years of proteozoic paleontology
has nevertheless accumulated an
impressive number of specimens
cabinets stretch floor to ceiling and
are crammed in back to back with
scarcely room to slide a piece of paper
between them
but these stores are mounted on wheels
driven by geared winding handles and as
the young paleontologist winds the
cabinet slowly rolls to the side
allowing her to walk along the newly
created space and commence her search in
earnest
the store is filled with brown shoeboxes
each full of proterozoic treasures
mounted on their glass slides and
labelled with a careful hand
[Music]
small red dots in the corner of some
labels indicate sections that are
priceless beyond measure
they are the designated holotypes the
first and presumably finest example of a
given species to which all subsequent
specimens can be compared
one box alone may contain a dozen slides
and in the entire room there are
thousands of such boxes
indeed there is no shortage of fossils
from which to draw our conclusions
ornamented microfossils of the type that
can only be formed by eukaryotic
internal complexity have been found in
rocks as old as 1.6 billion years
[Music]
dictiosphera germanosphera pterosperm
obsimopha simea and valeria are all
morphologically complex forms recovered
from the paleo-proterozoic chang cheng
group of northern china
[Music]
more ambiguous eukaryotic evidence is to
be found in even older instances of
exceptional preservation
fossils found in the 1.8
billion-year-old changu rocks in
northern china seem to show some of the
outer ornamentation expected from
eukaryotes but without any of the other
features to suggest complexity they are
not the most compelling of examples
remembering the tenet that exceptional
claims require exceptional evidence the
claim of the earliest eukaryotes must be
backed up by more than just a faint
pattern seen in the right light
[Music]
and yet remarkably even this example is
surpassed in age by another claimant for
the title of the earliest eukaryote
long thin spirals scrolled in dark
carbon were discovered in 1899 in 1.3
billion-year-old rocks of montana
at first they're interpreted as trace
fossils figurative footprints in the
sand left behind by a simple burrowing
worm
but in 1976 the fossil was reanalyzed
and set against the emerging picture of
late animal evolution to provide a new
interpretation
these curious doodles are extremely thin
flattened films of biological carbon up
to nine centimeters long if straightened
out
paleontologists believe them to be the
flattened remains of a large
seaweed-like organism that they have
named grypania
[Music]
in order to grow so large we assume
eukaryotic organization is at play
this is fine for the grapenia discovered
in montana it sits alongside other
examples of crude multicellularity but
when grapenia was discovered in rocks
more than 2 billion years old we must
challenge our assumptions once again
is the eukaryotic interpretation right
if so could these giant eukaryotic
specimens be among the first on earth
even older carbon-rich fossils have been
discovered in fine-grained shales dating
to 3.2 billion years old
some have argued for their eukaryotic
nature based on their large size
at 300 microns or three tenths of a
millimeter they are much smaller than
grapania but still larger than most
known bacterium
for this extraordinary claim however
there is no more evidence
of course other methods have been
devised to try and trace eukaryotes back
to their roots through earth history
just as the cellular machinery of these
more advanced cells can create
complicated structures on the outer wall
so too can they produce complicated
chemistry that no physical or
prokaryotic process can replicate
and so there is still no consensus on
how to verify the antiquity of a
molecule
other techniques can involve the
analysis of genetic change and
differences among living eukaryotes
reconstructing family trees of the
eukaryotic kingdoms and tracing those
trees back to their roots using an
assumed rate of evolutionary change
so-called molecular clocks can put a
date on the origin of eukaryotes with no
fossils necessary
some of these analyses also pin the
beginning of complex cells to a date of
around 2.7 billion years
but there is by no means a consensus on
the approach used to arrive at that date
there are so many assumptions in the
shape of the evolutionary tree and the
rate of change over evolutionary time
that any proposed dating becomes all but
meaningless
[Music]
today the pre-cambrian fossil record has
been revealed to us in all its glory
we are pretty certain we know how
complex eukaryotic life came about
and we have a good and growing history
of how it developed in its earliest
billion years or so
but finding the very first eukaryote the
basis for all complex life to come
is a much harder task
it is likely that eukaryotes as we know
them today actually came about gradually
beginning with the sealing of the
endosymbiotic pact and continuing with
the iterative development of internal
architecture throughout the relative
stasis of the boring billion
[Music]
approaching evolution from the more
traditional direction the invention of
membrane-bound organelles and nucleus as
well as an organizational cytoskeleton
and the internal chemistry needed to
support it would take an extremely long
time
thus instead of modern eukaryotes
appearing fully formed at some point in
the proterozoic we can expect a sliding
scale of complexity from cells to the
barely improved prokaryotes to cells
that are capable of combining in their
multitudes
differentiating and building the world
as we see it today
[Music]
this increasing simplicity as we trace
the fossil record deeper into the
precambrian is matched by the increasing
uncertainty we have when interpreting
these most ancient fossils
we may never know what was the first
true eukaryote
if there even is such a thing upon this
sliding scale
and yet with the wealth of fossil
evidence now available to us for the
bulk of the proterozoic
we do stand a better chance of
understanding the transitions that came
about after eukaryotes have taken the
stage
[Music]
the fog has been well and truly lifted
on one of the most cryptic periods of
earth's history
and as organisms grow ever larger and
more complex the late pre-cambrian world
begins to look ever more like the world
we inhabit today
[Music]
the next 800 million years
promise great things
for complex
eukaryotic life
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe and
leave a comment to tell us what you
think
next up we are no longer billions of
years in the past
but hundreds of millions
we're diving into one of the strangest
times in earth's history
when the entire planet was covered
by ice
[Music]
you